Hey!
My name is (throat noise)
That's my name, I'm here with Danny Devito
We're gonna play... Come close there don't be shy
Danny: I like to lick feet
We're gonna draw together, so, I'm gonna draw
and Danny is gonna guess uh, what I'm drawing. Here we go.
"I See Leg, or line, or nail"
I'm not done yet.
"I see crayon, or marker, or hockey stick"
Can you shut- "Or elbow".
"I see camouflage' please be q-  "or a broom, or rifle".
Be quiet.
"Oh I know, It's golf club".
Now you got it...
Congratulations
Ok, now we're going to draw a paintbrush, this is very exciting
"I see line, or knee, or string bead" - Please... - "or broom".
I'm not... i'm not done.
All right, I'm still work- "I see leg".
"I see shovel, or a spoon" - I'm trying- "or a knife" - can you... plea...
Be quiet. - "Or a cello. I see Clarinet" - I'm still... trying to draw.  "I see a violin".
I'm still... -"I See Seesaw".
I'm still drawing.
"Sorry, I couldn't guess it".
Oh.. that's too bad, You tried really hard. Draw a soccer ball and under- Okay, 20- a soccer ball.
That should be easy.
"I see line, or nose, I see potato, or circle"
Hey, that's not a potato
" I see steak, or bread, or bracelet, or poop"
"or helmet"
"I see bear, or mouse"
How do you see a bear?
" or dog"
What are you on about?
"Sorry I couldn't guess it"
You fucking idiot
Danny you're so stupid.
Oh I know , it's Mountain
Ho, that was fast, that was fast
Radio, ok  "I see diving board, or pillow, or keyboard, or bread, I see camera, or map. Oh I know, its radio."
Ok that's pretty impressive.
You're getting good at this Danny
Television.  "I see suitcase, or elbow, or square. or cooler. I see picture frame. I'm stumped." I'm stumped
Comin for dresser for all run wow [I] peep at four. Oh, I know it's television
She got it. I mean you got it well drawn. Thank you. That was so fun, Danny
That was so fun. What a game. I what a story draw an axe
D toothpaste or crayon or marker for megaphone? Oh aight? No its axe. This is the weirdest fucking game wait
Wait what am I supposed to draw- scissors.
I see frying pan, or mosquito, or cup
I see snowman or necklace, or ceiling fan, or mug. I see grapes, coffee cup or apple, or eyeglasses.
It's clearly a scissor!
Sorry, I couldn't guess it.
Well. I guess robots aren't going to take over anytime soon.
I see line. I see marker. Or knife. Or canoe. Or garden hose.
It is not a canoe.
I see ocean.
Or trombone.
Or animal (migration??)
(Or an aircraft carrier) You see a lot of shit- What are you smoking, honestly I'm getting worried about you
Or a diving board, or carrot. I see elbow. Or crocodile.
Or bracelet. Or hand.
I see bed.
Come on-!
Sorry, I couldn't guess it.
Ah, she was so close
I see moon.
Or nose.
Or potato.
Or circle.
Stop guessing potato!
It's clock.
Oh she got that? Damn.
Well if you're gonna guess every single fucking thing ever,
You can't just- [laugh]
I SEE BLEHJKSAHDKJASHDKJSAHDSAJHDHSAK
Oh, I got it right draw a dresser. Ok fine. I see golf club or suitcase
Or square.
Or bread.
Quiet- can you be quiet for one goddamn second.
I see map. I see clock. I see sandwich..
Or pants.
tHAT IS NOT A SANDWICH
-or popsicle!
I see picture frame. Or telephone. Or the Mona Lisa!
I see passport.
Or cooler.
Come on!
Sorry, I couldn't guess it..
I see diving board.
Or garden hose.
Or bottlecap!
I see pillow.
Or umbrella!
That's a hexagon right??
Sorry, I couldn't guess it!
I see line. Or boomerang. Or elbow.
Or arm.
Or finger.
I see diving board
Or screw driver
Or a bat!
I see roller coaster, or mustache or toothpaste
I see a key.
Or stitches.
Or dog.
Or fish.
Or frog.
I see mouse.
Or trumpet.
[laugh
Yeah, this thing is the best thing ever it's so amazing.
If you're gonna program a bot, at least-
-get the essentials, you know?
I see leg. I see rain.
I see jello!
I'm stumped.
[snicker] I see camoflage.
Or lobster.
[pewd's snickering continues]
Or zebra.
That's a zebra. You got it.
Danny: Let's play a different game.
All right, so this one is directly connected to Dan's mouth.. This is the sound he's making
You control- I'm controlling Danny's throat right now
[weird voicebox noises]
SHUT UP DANNY
[snicker]
[weird voicebox noises]
Why's this so funny?
[snicker]
[weird voicebox noises]
Oo.
Oh.
[weird voicebox noises]
This should not be this funny. Why am I laughing like a maniac?
Are you saying something Danny?
[weird voicebox noises]
Mmm. Well that was fun.
Danny: Let's play a different game.
[voice box noises]
Aight, final website that I wanna check out today
Is.. Uh
This website that lets you decide it decides if your picture is awesome or not, so let's see right now
if I am awesome or not
One percent chance. One percent.
[sad music]
What about Jack then.
[claps hands] GOT EM'
ZERO PERCENT. YA GOT 0, JACK
YOU SON OF A BI--- haha
33%, motherfucka!
You got 0% Jack, 0 potential.
Zero-
2- aight whatever.
African ethnicity. Got em'.
[laughing]
[dramatic music]
[LOUD YELLING] WHAT-
[LAUGHING]
[dramatic music]
[while laughing] what the fuck??
Are you kidding me.. you can't be serious?
How do you go from zero to 100 that quick- are you kidding me?
You can't be serious- this must be a coincidence
All right, what about this picture?
[DRAMATIC MUSIC] [while pewds is laughing]
[laughter]
You can't make this shit up.
Aight-
I think it's probably for the better if we move on from this one,
because It's not gonna be good.
It's already- it's already bad
What else do we got?
Let's play a different game.  [voice box noises]
Kay, I'm supposed to draw a uhhhh- lotion
[classical music]
Why is it all blue?
The fuck is happ- Oh shit
Ah shit.
Delete.
Okay- a lotion.
a lotion.
Wall Street journal, are you fucking kidding me. good guess?
[snicker]
SOMEONE GUESSED IT!
Hahahahaha yes, good job
Thanks for nothing. Okay.
He's drawing...
an xbox.
red ring of death.
It's uh...
[the hap is fuckening]
It's a letter.
Letterbox. Am I the only one-
oh that's the chat (good job, pewdie), xbox.
Great, we broke the website excellent
That's fine. I didn't want to have fun
I see spoon. Or pond.
Or potato.
Or bracelet.
Or peanut.
I see steak.
Or frog.
Or mouse.
I see dog. or tree. or rain. Or crocodile.
Or flying saucer.
Sorry, I couldn't guess it
I see line. Or keyboard. or cooler. Or belt. Or marker. I see hotdog. Or bathtub.
or anvil. or a hamburger.
I see pool. Or sink. Or aircraft carrier.
Or diving board.
I see speedboat!
Or submarine.
Or sandwich.
Or pond.
Sorry, I couldn't guess it.
Flamingo.
I see nail.
Or banana
Or nose.
Or swan
Or saxaphone
I see snake or peanuts or lollipop.
Danny: Oh I know, It's flamingo.
HEEEEY
[laughter]
You did it. How about that.
Great.
This is too much fun.
I see finger.
Or mountain.
Or toe.
I see crown.
Danny: I have no clue what you're drawing
SHUT UP
[laughter]
fuckin' asshole
sHUT UP! IT'S A HAND
Danny: Oh I know, It's hand!
[claps hands]
YES! [laughing]
[laughter]
ooooh my god...
So good at this game.
Well that was fun,
wasn't it?
That was- did you
DANNY!
what are you doin'?
Did you have fun today? Wow, that was that was a good video?
Definitely. I hope you enjoyed. Thank you for leaving a like and support
Next time let's draw together- that'll be fun
I'm sure it will work [sarcasm]. Check out another video here
If you enjoy watching! As always any support, that you leave is appreciated!
So thank you for leaving a like. And a comment.
And a subscribe.
And buy all my merch.
Twice. (do it.)
Thank you. Don't have any merch?
Don't worry about it.
Buy it anyway.
[kisses fist] Brofist.